while disney points fingers their racist
hypocrisy lingers
star wars is defending obi-wan kenobi
star moses ingram after she says she
received racist messages online since
the show premiered last week yikes beam
me up scotty
she shared
some on instagram which included use of
the n word and threats like your days
are numbered
shocking who knew hunter biden was
online
soon after the official star wars
account tweeted proud to welcome moses
ingram to the star wars family and
excited for riva's story to unfold if
anyone intends to make her feel in any
way unwelcome you have only one thing to
say we resist
and later they added there are more than
20 million sentient species in the star
wars galaxy don't choose to be a racist
now of course sending racist drivel is
racist have we learned nothing from when
captain kirk kissed lieutenant uhuru
or uhura
or hooray
but what fans took issue with is star
wars insinuating that the actions of a
few
people
represent them as a whole when they
reminded star wars of their previous
cowardice when it came to china back in
2015 when the force awakens was released
the american version of the poster
prominently featured black actor john
boyega but the chinese version minimized
his presence likely because their
sensors didn't want a black man featured
thus proving there's one evil empire
star wars won't resist
meanwhile other fans pointed out that
star wars content features many black
actors like sam jackson billy dee
williams or the fact that james earl
jones has played the voice of darth
vader for 45 years
well before i was born
but perhaps the story is meant to
distract us from the lousy reviews of
the new show let's take a look at a clip
from the first episode
obi-wan you shall meet your ultimate
demise oh god
who's that other guy with you oh oh oh
let's let's just steve steven our
roommates just your roommate well i mean
is my friend we practice the force on
each other no no no no it's cool i've
bought some friends too this is my
brunch crew oh um
do you care if steve and i come to
brunch with you totally as long as he
keeps that mask on steve don't you
embarrass me in front of my new brunch
friends
crunchy bronzy brother
[Applause]
cat you were adamant about doing this
story because you are you you're
considered one of the nation's uh top
experts
and being threatened
by star wars fans yes all right but
isn't it like isn't it one of those kind
of easy ways to get attention by
highlighting like out of zillions of
fans you like go like you actually
project the stuff yes
it's ridiculous such a weird thing to do
to be like here's our new character in
case you haven't noticed she is black so
don't be racist like if you take race
out of it and just imagine doing that
with anything you can see how nuts it is
like if you posted like you get married
you're like here i am and my new husband
and if you think he's a schlub and i can
do better don't say that
[Laughter]
i won't like it
like you're putting that out there it's
such a weird weird move i know you know
tires you can go on twitter and you can
find a hundred weirdos to validate any
kind of toxic belief
but meanwhile it's at that
self-selection thing there are millions
of people who say nothing but that's
boring
i mean i can't i don't dig too much of
my stuff but i will literally get at
least five or six racist tweets at least
a week or so from kill mead and
it's always the same thing if i come
across it block move on i don't have
time
but they never come to my house and do
it but yeah
what happened was here is and this is
where the woke they they picked their
battles
the fans were complaining about the box
being checked that the actual character
was in fact
something else right and they just
filled the box and that's what disney
does they fill the boxes and they
complained about it so and then they
took the worst of them they found the
the complete morons who make racist
arguments because they can't formulate
their own thought and that's the one
they focus on to give everyone attention
so they won't no one will criticize a
bad acting or b it doesn't fit because
that's how the woke do that's how they
do their thing like look the sister
shouldn't have to ever hear someone
calling the n-word on the stuff at the
same time why are you giving it air yeah
don't i mean because i refuse to give
anybody any air that talks any trash
about me because that's all they're
doing it for once they get air then they
sit in their little chat group and see i
saw him you know like i can't believe he
all i get is how would you block me and
then block again it's that simple you
don't give it air it's not an issue yeah
shannon what do you think about the old
china aspect of this it's like
uh you know okay you guys can be racist
because we need your money
right and they and they change things
like they take things out of movies they
took something out of harry potter
whichever you know um the studio did
that remove me from the last james bond
movie well i mean
surprisingly it's surprising
from the set
for harassing and surprisingly different
it also seems you were removed from the
u.s edition yes
you're gonna be in so much trouble i'm
gonna tell you after this segment
because you have mixed star wars star
trek marvel the fans of these things are
not happy when those things get
interposed and intermixed so i just i'm
worried for your safety well you know
what that makes them a bigot i mean if
they want to segregate
movies sci-fi characters you would be a
good bonds villain though i think i'd be
a great book mr bond thing i would i
think that what they all have in common
is i will never watch any of them
i mean i'm a nerd
i'm a true nerd this just isn't my area
of nerd expertise i just know you don't
mix them what's your area of nerd um i
will always be reading books you know
that
nerd let's beat her up
it wouldn't be the first time you know
what and i don't mean that i'm against
beating up women
out there
push-ups right now
here's the funny thing about this this
is what i find very funny okay so
they've been black characters in star
wars for 45 years
so in order to get angry and say that
people you have to assume that people
are more racist now than they were then
that's not that categorically can't be
true right well not if you ask me if you
have cnn they'll tell you the the
opposite right yeah and skelter and
company and all those morons you know
it's like it's ironic to me that we have
to talk about racism just to inject like
you were saying just to inject it back
into the political landscape or the
media landscape when i was in government
i got death threats i got called the
worst things i got stuff sent to my
house i didn't i didn't give it air time
i just said here you go here's the
security check move on i got emails all
the time but they were just they
monopolized the industry to say that
can't happen to people who are
conservative republican or work for
trump and so we just never talk about it
we just did the job and we just kept
punching on and moving on and now
they're losing on everything from amazon
to disney to twitter to what have you so
now they're like okay let's take the
star wars empire make everyone racist
again has anybody ever showed up at your
house yes you yes
in your house i just wanted to see if he
remembered
did you read the card
um
the the secret service has it yeah
so he did violate the restraining order
there were some polaroids in the card
cash those i had given me hours to get
that angle
how to buy a full floor-length mirror
the lighting was tremendous thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else